au niveau sensation c'est comment par
rapport à autre chose est-ce qu'il y a
un moment où vraiment tu as une une
montée d'adrén il y a du speed en fait
tu tu es en statique en l'air pendant un
bout de temps et norement av avant que
tu touches l'eau en fait tu renvoies
l'elle pour que ça fuse sur la flotte
quoi
mais c'est bien cool quoi de d'arriver
d'être un peu rock and roll sur l'eau
quoi pas essayer que juste de marquer
des points et et ouais voilà c'est tu
cherches quand même à faire le showud
ouais ouais ouais c'est c'est je pense
que c'est c'est ce qui est le plus
intéressant dans le sport quoi c'est un
sport rien spectaculaire il faut monter
un peu ce qu'on ce qui est capable de
faire et essayer d'avoir le Power sur
quoi
i'll try to make it
as as
possible
name dir başarır Mar
maner
freedom fun and
friendship
pas
very surprised about the place I mean we
have nice contest area beautiful day
sunny wind speaking
up make
as as
possible
make
as
where I'm living is which is in Ventura
it's it's very much in in the winter
like Maui you get the good swell and so
I'm very much motivated to you know to
surf and windsf when the conditions are
right admittedly you know I used to go
everyday windsfing and just sometimes
kite and eventually the kting
overtook i mean that's what I miss from
K is the the wave the wave action you
know the adrenaline and the buzz you get
from being in the waves that's the only
point that's missing for me in the sport
but there's something about you know
especially if you can start getting
waves good enough or you can start
getting tubed and stuff like that I mean
that's i don't know it starts it's a
freaky freaky
sensation
hospitity it was perfect i just wish
there was more win the first couple of
days but I think everyone all the
writers you especially it was great I'm
reallyad that we are have sponsored this
event thank you
for
so do you know this guy marin Ohin is my
idol this is the guy this is the man
the first for me was great won the last
h with a lot of good guys with M m with
from Israel i think for me was the best
for me and now I go
against this is not good
but for was
great ah yeah um i wouldn't want to
disappoint him and let him win
so no it's better to sell with friends
it's more fun to sell heat with friends
so what about the weather now with the
weather i have no idea it's cloudy it's
a bit cold it's not very windy apart
from that it's all
good k
your
okey
well we are like a mistake with Laurel
and Aurelia because we
thoughtes just up everything we
has very good level so I'm not in
confidence
it was tough today the wind was kind of
light and um onshore it was
on était tous un peu énerv on pasant la
semaine là aujourd'hi on a donné tout ce
qu'on pouvait tout ce qu'on avait on éta
tellement motivé que cétait vraiment
tout cas comme oné ave filles vraent
fait plaisir sur l'eau et bon
voilà
on espère que le vent va se lever là
donc déjà il s'est mis dans la dans la
bonne direction
donc il a soufflé pendant un mois avant
donc là il s'est reposé quelques jours
maintenant il va repartir de plus belle
donc on espère et puis avoir une semaine
de folie pour avec du Spectacle du Monde
et puis bah des couleurs du soleil donc
voilà donc on va avoir une belle semaine
je pense pour le moment ça se présente
très très bien euh je crois que ça ça va
être le plus beau événement de de tout
le tour et là le vent il se lève petit à
petit et je suis très
positif
steady and the conditions are really
nice um you can get really close to the
crowd with the offshore windn we have
here and it's really one of the best
places we do a competition in the
year
ça
so today we have the right conditions to
start with the first ladder of the men
we will run first heat first round and
second round of the men and then we go
with the women and if we have time we go
all the way to the end andably have the
winner
on a toujours des nouvelles figures qui
arrivent quand vous débarquez donc on a
préoné un petit peu bon maintenant le
vent est en train de monter donc on se
retrouve un peu plus dans autre élément
dans le vent léger j'étais pas trop trop
à l'aise là ça ça devient de mesur mieux
donc maintenant ben voilà là on a on a
une fin finale calédonienne déjà donc
fil mais je VO allez bonne
chance les
jeux
résultat
avec
ette
prèreation
too
no
benur
ouis souvenir on aura pas l'occasion de
venir ici tous les jours
par magnifique c'est
incroyableous on voit VO restetemps on
va venir vous
voir aprs êes obligé de lâcher la voile
ou quo ce soit effectivement bon à terme
s'il y a pas de bateau vous lâchez votre
fusé vous avez le siffl déjà on prépare
de départ cour pour bien
sassurerit de sécurité sur avant de
démarrer donc les fusé le
SIAL le vest
courur SPE c'est loin quand même avec le
vent qui a je crois que les cuisses vont
chauffer par les muscles B c'est
physique pour un muscle la cuisse gauche
c'est ça le plus dur en fait c'est de
gérer gérer au maximum la course par
rapport à ça et puis bon ben de toute
façon on est là pour souffrir mais bon
le plaisir il est quand même là c'est
génial quoi ça r d'être très très
physique
ça j'ai démarrer un peu plus au vent que
mano et Charles de l'eau j'étais à peu
près à leur niveau mais à peu près 100 m
plus haut et donc j'ai vu Charles qui
qui est tombé donc ça m'a mis en
confiance après mano aussi donc j'ai
commencé à prendre de la avance et après
ben j'ai tracé
tracé il y a à peu près 3 ans et demi 4
ans j'ai vu un reportage sur à la télé
avec Raphaël S qui faisait des bonds de
folie tout je l'ai tout de suite appelé
j'ai dit bon ben là il faut que je fasse
quelque chose avec le kite parce que
c'est vraiment génial quoi et on a
démarré doucement et et on a mis du
temps à apprendre et moi j'ai j'ai
vraiment accroché à partir du momentù je
suis remonté au vent quoi revenu à mon
point de départ et là j'ai dit non c'est
bon c'est un sport qui va éclater et
surtout en cadoni on a analysé qui est
qui est top et et puis voilà l'évolution
en kadonie c'est fait en espace de 3 ans
et ça a été du délire quoi donc en fait
moi je je vis de ça je vide de ça bon je
suis pas professionnel je fais pas les
je suis pas le tour malheureusement j'ai
pas trop le temps donc je je j'ai mon
magasin je fais la mise au point des
planches de de kite on importe bien sûr
donc tout ce qui est a et accessoir et
euh en fait on est un petit peu le fer
de lance du du du kite surf en Nou
canonie donc on on fait un petit peu
attention à ce qu'on dit à ce qu'on fait
et et surtout on essaie de motiver les
les
gens dans le bon sens depuis 2001 ça a
été en fait une rampe de lancement de de
fou au niveau du du niveau des gars donc
là ça nous a amené
euh bah tout ce qu'on pouvait faire en
fly B des Julien Soura des marchines qui
ont des styles complètement différents
donc ça nous a montré vraiment des des
horizons complètement différents de des
possibilités du kite et et là ça a été
un entraînement
entre guillemets parce que bon ici c'est
vrai qu'on navigue pratiquement toute
l'année donc on navigue pour notre
plaisir et en même temps bon on évolue
au fur à mesure et là il y a il y a
vraiment un
engouement qui qui a amené les jeunes à
prendre un niveau de folie et bon moi
j'essayer de de suivre le rythme ce qui
est pas ce qui est pas forcément évident
mais je pense qu'on a appris énormément
du du Cap WT de l'année dernière et je
pense que ça ça va ça va pour cette
année peut-être payer quoi
ici ils ont l'occasion de naviguer
beaucoup plus souvent que nous ils ont
un plan d'eau idéal pour pour naviguer
tout le temps pas très loin de de
l'atelier donc ils ont une mise au point
une recherche qui est beaucoup plus
poussé par rapport à nous lui il fait
ses planches il navigue il fait tester
et donc ça évolue beaucoup plus vite
chez nous vu qu'on a pas de shaper déjà
on a aucun mec qui fait des planches de
de cite donc on est à la recherche de
planches
de de bonnes planches de cite
quoi ben tout a commencé avec la planche
à wal et quand on a eu le fly surf qui
est arrivé en
cadonie j'ai automatiquement changé de
de fabrication donc j'ai commencé à
fabriquer des fly surf c'était en 99 et
depuis ben on fait plus que ça avant on
était plutôt en directionnel après on
est passé un peu mutante et maintenant
je suis à fond dans le twin typ et les
dernières évolutions c'est surtout le le
flex planch on réflex ai et niveau
taille on a tendance à pas mal raptissir
donc autour on a 1 35 1 32 même par
contre on élargit légèrement donc ça
donne des planches qui ont beaucoup de
bump et niveau performance ça marche pas
mal on a sorti cette figure en fait on
s'assoit sur la planche et sans les
mains donc forcément no foot et on part
720 et voilà bon au début on savait pas
trop comment on allait appeler sol et
puis bon ro R et puis voilà c'est les
fraises des fraisiers de
F lâche vine en arrière sur la Celle et
c'est
parti alleors courage allez la terre la
terre tiensm F tiensm
je sais pas ce qu' le don à Bou bê mais
son pas bouffé
maisén
numé viens voir viens voir oui
je sais pas ce qu'ils ont bouffé mais
ils sont vachement
nerveuxère
américainir en
place les petit garç ouis pourquoi il
son
lui
et il a pas
tenu yesterday we had the full day of
Competion and we compled the winner
Braet which means that we have a
champion and today we have to run
doubleimination theple
is of the round of winneretc each other
then
wiersc the
winneret
tir
avec
s'il vous
plat c'est parti c'est parti
you want to man now yeah
like just i think I might need a bit
more wind than this but we'll
see
trs for garçons s'il vous plaît unement
inovation pour ce garçon qui a ça a bien
évolué le vent est monté bon là on a
retrouvé nos conditions
alisées moyen donc 20 25 nud et au top
quoi
OK
prochain BR pour la finale pourqui
pas
OHS the level of competition was really
good too so it was a good
event
i
motie
man
and move your butt the music in get up
and but you got get up and move your
buttic andve but
got
bangal bang
bangal
કનો ક surfચ બ because is everybody Go
have the St and only
one here because s the other
wind and here
for this is
the may this one it's very good and
small one it's not so heavy it's good
one I think I want to this try so you
like the twin tip style more than sty
yeah this more easy for
me
you know I
go go RER this is my te i I feeling so
good to go water this is
my
es divertido uno se diierteo
competici se
sioeree
go to
kobakavan this is
myite the Dominican rider i think
different style because you know the
same style a little bit with chrer T
and because the father
the Dominican and have a little bit the
same style i believe a lot in the
Dominican uh riders because they are
training a lot and they have shown
already that they are good riders they
only been sailing for two years or
something like that for the oldest one
and they are already at the top level so
I believe in
them because they go for it and they
train a l and they want to
everything
so we came here today because what
happened yesterday was really bad luck
we didn't have any win at all therefore
we checked the forecast and we took the
decision and exp to somes and
CH
we been here for years alreadyd
so I think we had a little bit but any a
nice place and we will come back next
that's
for
we no chance
final winneret
but at least we had some great time here
and we went on different places
that we never went before so I think
overession a good
event
je